good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday hope
everybody's having a great day it is
like uh I don't even know how to
describe today um it's a weird day let's
be real it's a weird day I hope
everybody enjoyed yesterday oh sorry hey
J how you doing I'm doing good Claude
thanks I agree with you it's a weird day
there's a lot going on here in our
studio of course it is Pub day for my
children's book which we are going to
celebrate that's just a non-negotiable I
know you're like feeling like it's not
important I don't care Jackie wrote a
book it's not that I'm feeling like it's
not important I feel like so many people
are messaging me being like you should
still like promote it and it's not like
I feel awkward you know cuz the only
person I'd be offending I post is myself
like no one's going to like cancel me
the people who do the canceling don't
give a [__] about what's going on right
so it's just that like I just don't I'm
not feeling it okay well I'm feeling it
for the both of us I woke up this
morning feeling it more like camper and
counselors stand with Israel the whole
bunk stands with Israel no it's so true
by the way it's zus bunk it's a
heartwarming book and we need some
heartwarming things right now no and
like you should be very proud it's
really I am proud but I also feel like
the book will the book is out now you
can buy it wherever you get your book
it's also like kind of out of stock on
Amazon because it's so popular so we
really can't even promote it that much
well it is out of stock the first
printing sold out the second printing
arrives on Thursday so if you get it on
Amazon now like you'll get it by Friday
uh but it's crazy so that's what I mean
like the first printing sold out like
I've sold a lot of books I can promote
the book any other time we have books to
sell like next week the week after um so
it just felt a little less imminent that
I go so hard today but I am really
excited and I'm mostly excited to hear
what you guys think about the book if
you pre-ordered the book Barnes & Noble
shipped it out this weekend let's talk
about the unprofessionalism of Barnes &
Noble I'm kind of obsessed sorry like me
too because also if you ordered it on
Barnes & Noble like you're not like
other girls who just went to Amazon you
know Prime Del you're probably like a
real um patron of literature cuz you
know who ordered it on Barnes & Noble
Dana and she's a patron of Literature
Like I said patron of literature so she
got it a few days ago sneak peek so if
you ordered on Barnes & Noble you
probably have it already and I'm really
curious to hear what people think J it's
such a ray of light I literally read it
yesterday like sobbing sobbing it's so
good I'm so proud of you I hope
everybody picks up a copy it's the thing
is it is that book you think it's not
but it is it's really wonderful I've
sent it to a few influencers too and
they like sent me pictures of their kids
like reading it and loving it and it's
so nice to see just like kids with the
book and enjoying it CU it's it's for
kids the illustrations are so bright and
colorful the message is heartwarming you
know the camp message of strength the
counselor is not molesting the camper
like oh my God very it's very pure and
we need more things like that in this
world I was not expecting you to say
molest are you okay no like it's just I
know you mean it's it's pure and it's
joyous and it's sweet I it's good it's
good it's good okay she said what she
said and if you want to hear like what
goes down there's kind of like a a crazy
moment in the children's book something
happens at the lake that you're not
going to see coming and I think
everyone's we really gassed it up a lot
the craziest thing happens at the lake
there's a pirouette okay like the lake
is a pivotal scene for our camper it's
the arc the story some would say it's
when she really begins to trust the
counselor it's like the bridge you know
it's like if there's a song this is the
bridge but it's nothing that crazy no I
think it's psychotic except you do get
to see the counselor in a two-piece
let's talk about the counselor let's
talk about the counselor the counselor
character is extremely sexy honestly the
book is kind of like not pure like you
said it was because the counselor is
very hot like as counselors are it's so
true and that's also like when you're a
kid and you're you're at camp and your
counselor is like this older girl who
like wears makeup that really is the
lens in which you see her like she could
be a beast but you
look you look at her you're like oh my
God this adult this gorgeous like you
you really look up to her yeah and she's
yours you know when you're an
eight-year-old like what 18 yearold cool
girl is really talking you hanging out
with you looking after you but that's
the beauty of camp and the bunk it's
like that girl is taking care of you and
she's going to show you her ways how to
become like her it's so true it's so
true I just did stop podcast yesterday I
think it's coming out this week and we
were talking about Camp cuz she's not a
camp person um and I was just explaining
to her like the role of a counselor in a
Camper's life also on Thursday we have
our redheads episode about camper and
counselor coming out I heard it's it's
Peak comedy it's one of it's my favorite
pot no offense to the toast okay I won't
say it so generally yeah I don't feel
like we need to paint with brushstrokes
you know like just say what you're going
to say top five my favorite podcast
episode I've ever recorded in my life
and I've recorded thousands with me with
L
turd and maybe yesterday's episode is
also another top five so it's just a big
week for podcasting it is a big week for
podcasting it's a big week for you
congratulations everyone pick up a copy
the camper the counselor.com you can buy
it anywhere and if it says out of stock
on Amazon like you'll get it in a week
just no like the warehouse will be
replenished on Thursday so it's not
going to be a really long wait time or
anything and I'm really grateful for
everyone who got the book that I sold
out in my first printing I didn't even
think I would sell that many books like
in the course of your right and it was
first week so that's so awesome and
please let me know what your kids think
of the book like that's what I'm most
excited to hear the winding Camp roads
give me goosebumps and chills and you
know what I'll give you guys a little
bit more of a teaser yeah don't pick
that book up I won't pick that book up
cuz my drinks are behind there I need to
stay hydrated maybe you should read my
favorite page which one you know my
favorite page the nature page Greenery
The Greenery okay so I don't know that I
i' I've shown you guys this when camper
and counselor level set on the bunk
porch it's kind of a a Coming of Age
moment yeah the counselor is it's just
like letting camper know what's in store
right I don't want to spoil too much
this is when she's like getting cracking
on with the girlies as they would say on
love Island there's highs and lows cuz
she's having fun one moment she's
bugging out the
next this is Claudia's oh that's the
lake scene oh oh pivotal pivotal this is
Claudia's favorite page illustration
wise like to me that really captures the
essence of the book like it's so pure
look how look look at the the Simka the
joy in her eyes the joy in her eyes
should I read the page but kind of like
deep I don't know if you should just be
giving it away for free this a business
you if you do want to just like know
what the story is and know what we're
talking about and know what happened at
the lake you can get it on Kindle or
wherever you get ebooks it's available
as an ebook if you read it on your
Kindle it'll be in black and white as
the Kindle is black and white but if you
read it on the Kindle app on your iPhone
or iPad it's in color cute so they put
the graphics in a Kindle kids book M how
cute so if you're on the road with your
kid and counselors their favorite book
pull it up on your Kindle even on your
phone on your Kindle app I have the
Kindle app on my phone iPad I have my
Kindle all the time 100% but if you
really just want to know the plot and
what your girly did and how it thickens
check it out Kindle ebook e-reader what
are e-readers other than Kindles let's
talk about e-readers I'm so glad you
brought that up the [__] is an e-reader
Kindle no I think it's no I know it's
like an electric reader I'm not dumb but
I think it like if you read on your iPad
like that's your e-reader right yeah but
there I think are other e-reader devices
that aren't Kindle Nook Barnes & Noble
makes their own it's called Nook yeah
that would be a e reader nobody has it
like let's be real if you have a Nook
you can get camper and counselor too and
if you have a Nook like maybe try
Kindle so honestly I have to say I'm so
looking forward to doing this episode I
feel like I have not been off my phone
in the last four days and I'm just
actually like really looking forward to
talking about moronic lunacy like
meaningless coverage of things that
don't matter yeah and I did s's podcast
yesterday after doing ours I was feeling
like how am I gonna get out of it switch
gears and I did and it was just so nice
to chitchat and all that darkness is
still waiting but to have an hour just
to bring some levity it felt really good
and that's what we do here and we're
going to try and do it but we're also
going to be real because you know what
we're not covering problematic
celebrities yeah no and the the
crossover of celebrities um and like
what's going on right now it's really
hard to ignore and like not me losing
respect for everybody like unfollowing
everybody on Instagram like if if you
feel me being Curt and short today it's
cuz I have no respect for this person
yeah but I chose stories from
unpraised by the way you would know
because everything Kelly does is
headline news it would have been a
People magazine story today so let me
check let me check in on our friend KS I
don't want to nothing in feed but I'm
not going to SL until you know until we
know for sure no nothing nothing on her
story but maybe she posted when it
happened andir whatever like I don't
want to be that person probably not
maybe just interesting to note
interesting to note maybe on her show
she'll say something probably not but
maybe
maybe so we're just going to try our
best to be the girls that you know and
love because honestly I feel like I
really need it today yeah me as well so
anything else new with you that you want
to share with the class yes I thought
You' never ask I watched Beckham I know
it literally feels like a lifetime ago
was like PW no BW before war and I
enjoyed it so much like I I think maybe
I was it was a little bit before my time
I wasn't invested in pop culture when
David and and Victoria Beckham like took
on the scene you were six I was six and
I was American so it really I didn't
realize like how much of a big deal it
was in the UK I was obsessed I thought
the documentary was about their family
and them it's about David and of course
that includes Parts about Posh but I'm
obsessed and I just had like so many
thoughts on the whole thing I my
introduction to David Beckham and I
really wish they had spoken about it was
Bend It Like Beckham the best movie of
all time Kier didn't mention it not once
I was shocked because I feel like that's
a obviously he storyed he scored that
goal from the half line I watched the
first five minutes if you half line
what's it called mid Midfield Midfield I
watched the first 5 minutes um DW during
war I was trying I was trying to get out
yeah yeah some things are a little too
mindless like you know yeah no but
that's it's a it's a fine line it's a
tough line to walk but he's obviously a
great soccer player would have been
always but I feel like having a movie
Nam your name in the title such a great
movie right adds to your legacy 100% it
was really and they didn't mention it I
was shocked and disappointed that they
didn't bring it up I did want to say
like my takeaway though and I don't know
if this is everyone's takeaway I didn't
realize how much David Beckham had been
through like did you know that thing at
the World Cup no so he's like the best
player he's literally 12 years old and
he's the best player in the entire world
and so England Taps him for the World
Cup team they make it all the way to the
finals they're playing Argentina
Argentina vers Britain there's like
history there in in history but also in
soccer like it's a big
matchup some like ass hat player who
actually ends up being filmed in the
documentary he he gave his his take on
it like shoves him to the ground like
whatever and David gives him a little
kick he gives him a little Frost with
his leg gets thrown out of the game
England is just Draught they're furious
at him like talk about being canceled
furious at him at David being like
that's so petulant and immature he was
literally 22 and like the the guy the
other guy started it so you know what
and it was such a minor offense it's
really they say worthy of a yellow flag
not a red flag that gets you thrown out
did the other guy get thrown out no but
the other guy was in the documentary I
smell a conspiracy the other guy was in
the documentary and at the very end he
was like did you feel like they
overreacted and he shouldn't have gotten
a red flag and he was like yeah it was
like a really big deal like if you know
the history oh my God was he cancelled
he couldn't he could not like he
couldn't even fly into the country like
he was so hated I had no idea about that
so whatever I'm learning all this about
his career and what I learned and I
don't feel like this was the intentional
takeaway from the documentary but like
what a losery way to go out do you know
how he ended his his career in LA right
okay in La which isn't losery it's like
he made $250 million to play for like a
year um but what I didn't know at the
time is like while the LA Galaxy was
pouring money into their team the Major
League Soccer League like wasn't pouring
money into the league he was literally
playing on like in Parks like it was
like it was like lowbudget energy and it
was so weird to see like this prolific
player playing on like former football
fields they had like the numbers The
Yards like etched in yeah and he he
moved his whole family there Victoria's
so happy she hated living in Spain Spain
media hated her she just hated it did
she want to go back to the UK she wanted
to go like anywhere else but she ended
up um loving La the second they moved
there she's like somebody once told me
when I moved there that La is like re
for famous people and like they could
take their like in in Madrid when they
live there they would literally walk
their kids to school and with a camera
right behind them like so crazy no
privacy in La they have like private
yards for the kids to do drop off she
was like it was just amazing and after
playing there for 5 minutes he was like
I ha it here rightfully so because it
was loserville Central and he goes to
Milan I guess it's like the offseason
now in La he goes to Milan leaves his
team high and dry his teammates are like
speaking out against him being like what
the [__] Victoria's not leaving she
stays with the kids like they're so
happy there he ends up playing in Milan
and being like this isn't right like I
he comes home he makes it right with all
of his teammates who were like speaking
out against him and he ends up playing
there for five years I think really just
to keep Victoria happy and to obviously
make a ton of money the LA Galaxy
doesn't even exist anymore it's called
like a new team at the LA football club
it was like such a flop that's how his
career ended and then he retired after
that oh no I'm sorry after that he went
to Paris played for Paris for 30 seconds
and retired in Paris wow well I actually
have a lot of respect for him for
choosing his family life okay but if you
see it through the lens of the
documentary like he never once chose his
family life like until the end when that
was the only thing that was left for him
yeah and honestly like Victoria put up
with a lot yeah Justice for Victoria but
at least he didn't make them all move
and he like moved to Milan moved to
Paris he wasn't even there for the birth
of his second child like he really was
like and he said like I love my he said
it in press conferences at the time and
he said it now he's like I love my
family familyes everything but
football's number one oh wow cuz the way
you're describing it I could say like he
chose to play for a losery team to set
his family up financially for the rest
of their lives in a city that they would
love so he left Madrid because they they
were starting with him like there was
infighting with the coaches and he's
like [__] this I'm taking the 250 M so
he didn't even leave for his wife he
left because of his pride in Madrid oh
wow but it all kind of worked out I just
didn't realize how many like scandals he
kind of went through in the very small
insular Soccer World yeah and also I
didn't realize what a man what a man
what a man what a man what a mighty good
man so hot like you know never in your
life saw a man that looked like that
like shaved his head so hot grew his
hair to his shoulders so hot buzzcut
like and his hair was like a thing and
every time he did something with his
hair it was major major news and I
understand why like it it's his face cuz
you could have any haircut and you're
the hottest man alive yeah even now so
good-looking they did the like a lot of
the filming was like so close up yeah
because so they had David sit down and
watch old footage and like literally
zoomed in on his face to get his
reactions which was so it
it was unnecessary then do that to
Victoria but I feel like there are so
many sports documentaries right now
there are so many documentaries and you
have to set yourself apart like with
your filming you need to be creative and
artistic you want to win those Awards
it's competitive so they're trying
something new it was really good like
highly recommend I will continue
watching it at some point I was I think
I was enjoying it and I was learning a
lot and he also like put some like
soccer's always been like huge but not
really in entertainment and in pop
culture when he started dating Victoria
like they said that they were like just
as famous as Charles and Diana at the
time they were like soccers Charles and
Diana and they put a Target on his back
like a lot of the coaches and the
managers didn't like like he was you
know doing fashion shows and he became a
brand and he was making so much money
you know as the faces of watches and
atleisure companies and they didn't like
that it it made a lot of coaches dislike
him and he was call he was Nam and names
I love that it was really good I really
enjoyed it okay I'm going to finish
watching and so hot like and when they
covered their wedding they were like
they were just like a little crazy at
the time so they this big wedding and
they told everyone to wear black or
white and they're like why would they
tell people to wear white they both
showed up in bright purple and they were
like sitting talking about it now in the
documentary being like yeah that was
like weird Victoria stood by her
decision but they were like yeah we
don't really know why what is she like
not what I expected and you know what
they give they have a lot of behind the
scenes H Spice Girls footage and I think
the the POV when we were like obsessed
with the Spice Girls is like she was
cold right no she was like I was really
awkward and I didn't really know how to
deal with a lot of what was going on
with the Spice Girls but then also with
David so I just like stayed silent and
so many the other girls were so outgoing
so I just like let them do their thing
and she got and that really translated
into a lot of how the media talked about
her like stone cold ice queen but she's
really not like that and she's she was
fiercely defensive of David and she's
like I hate football I hate soccer um I
she was literally calling people out by
names like shame on you shame on you
shame on you like she was very involved
in everything oh my God and he just
loved her so like he would be in this
training driving driving 7 hours to
London cuz he was in Manchester driving
s hours there and back to hang out with
her for 20 minutes like and it a lot of
his teammates really mad he wasn't
focused he didn't care oh he loved her
so and still does then there was the
infidelity thing and we talked about it
last week no they pretty much said he
cheated and that's why she [__] hated
Madrid because Madrid caused him to
cheat because she was like I'm not going
until you have a set my kids are in
school so I'm not going to leave until
you set everything up for us so I think
she waited like almost a year to come
and in that year and in that year yeah
and
she she's a queen she didn't let and so
that's why that's why they stayed in La
she's like [__] after everything I'm
finally happy sit down yeah it's her
turn take a seat yeah it was interesting
it was complex Dynamics Nicola was in it
for half a second we need a documentary
about her yeah so I thought it was going
to be more about them and I found the
soccer stuff interesting but I needed
more more Posh well that's also because
it was called Beckham so you think it's
about a family not a person yeah it was
great I loved it great well thank you
for your recap oh and D David Beckham
Jewish King proud supporter of Israel so
I feel good promoting his his Netflix
documentary everybody should watch it
love that yeah okay so without further
Ado I think so it's it's only been 20
minutes let's get into the fast five
stories that you need to know we're
using you know we're playing fast and
loose with the word need oh yeah we
always do we always do yeah that you're
GNA here's the fast five stories that
you're going to hear today whether you
like it or not today's episode of the
toast is brought to you by Lululemon
because praise the lord it's legging
season we don't have to shave our legs
anymore we're all wearing leggings and
sweaters and there's really only one
option when it comes to purchasing
leggings and that's Lululemon cuz they
they've got something for everyone if
you live a really active lifestyle like
you run or you jog check out the fast
and free leggings that are powered by
their new Lux fabric it's a weightless
on body sensation with Incredible
coverage designed for those looking for
a legging that gives them complete
Freedom while running or jogging now if
you are a little less active like you
you work out and then you love to run
errands right after wear leggings you
know just doing active Tings check out
the Wonder Trin leggings their most
Innovative fabric the everlux fabric is
their fastest drying fabric so if you
like to work out in the morning and then
do a bunch of things in the afternoon
you know work or you run gr run to the
grocery store this is perfect for both
the fabric is really really drying so
once you're done working out no crotch
sweat no stains no embarrassing stains
keep the leggings on and keep going girl
and then the Align leggings which are my
favorite because I love the Align
collection from Lululemon I have a ton
of stuff from that collection it's the
new fabric so this is perfect for you
know the more casual low intensity
workouts or if you just like to wear
leggings as casual wear which I
absolutely love to do I'm always wearing
leggings so that's the Align leggings
whatever you're looking for Lululemon
has you covered whatever your lifestyle
is so get into all the Lululemon
leggings at lululemon.com that's
lululemon.com lululemon.com sweat a
weather it's here you guys praise be
thank you Lululemon for ushering in this
gorgeous time of year today's episode is
also brought to you by ring concierge
the leading luxury Jeweler Jeweler
committed to designs by women for
everyone ring concierge offers
accessible on Trend and wearable
everyday fine jewelry for how the Modern
Woman stacks and layers or pieces so
it's fine jewelry but it's meant to be
worn every day I think this is the best
thing you can give someone as a gift
because it it's made really well it
lasts a really long time you're not
going to be tarnishing your skin also if
you're like you know expecting a gift
coming up like a birthday an anniversary
maybe you know Hanukkah or Christmas
send a link to the person in your life
from ring concierge because you know
you're getting a good gift they create
custom handcrafted engagement rings as
well so if that time of year is uh is
around the corner send the link they
specialize in getting you the biggest
diamond within your budget so they make
fine jewelry at every price point and
it's a you know no surprise why it's a
celebrity called favorite jewelry brand
it's so wellmade it's so beautiful I got
a gift from Jackie actually a pair of
earrings from ring coners and I have to
say it's like it's the best thing I
think she would consider it a A+
investment and of course we have a code
for you guys so the code is 20 toast 20
t o s you can shop find jewelry at ring
con.com use that code for 20% off your
find jewelry purchase I feel like it's
so much better to invest in good jewelry
pieces that you'll have forever as
opposed to just like buying crap that
you really can't wear for more than a
few weeks this is really wellmade it's
really beautiful it's a really reputable
brand I love their Instagram it's like
one of my favorite pages to follow for
jewelry Ino and especially for
engagement rings so if you are someone
you know is looking to get engaged check
out the ring concierge highly recommend
love their work and again we have a code
so you can shop the find jewelry at ring
concierge.com and use code 20 toast for
20% off your fine jewelry purchase
today's episode is also brought to you
by caroway a brand favorite here at the
toast so whether you're making a fall
Feast a quick girl dinner or you know it
is that time of year according to uh the
weather a chil you got to do so in your
carway homes non-toxic products they
make cozy Seasons safe and stylish so
their internet famous kitchen wear is a
staple for any home it comes in a
variety of modern Shades to fit with
whatever design aesthetic you have you
know you have a a light and bright
kitchen a dark and Moody kitchen
whatever it is carway got you covered
they're non-toxic kitchen wear features
a chemical-free ceramic coating food can
be prepared with peace of mind that no
hard to pronounce chemicals will leech
into your healthy ingredients so you
might you might be asking what's
different about caroway why is this
kitchen wear different from all other
kitchen wees well here's why first of
all it's non-toxic so their products are
made without any toxic materials so no
hardto pronounce chemicals are going to
leech into your healthy ingredients that
you spent a lot of money on it's easy
cooking so they naturally slick surface
means minimal oil or butter is required
for easy cleaning so if you hate cooking
because of the dishes this makes it so
much easier or if you live with someone
who leaves you know cheese on a pan and
then puts it in the sink this is a
carway for the girls who are cleaning up
after the men in their lives that's
that's what I'll say and it's really
well- loved so visit carway home.com
theet toast to take advant Vantage of
this limited time offer for 10% off your
next purchase this deal is exclusive for
our listeners so visit carway home.com
theeast or use code the toast at
checkout Caraway it's non-toxic cookware
made Modern and the toast has got you
covered at carway home.com theeast or
just code the toast first up Gwyneth
palro uses her Oscar as a door stop I
saw she said it works perfectly no more
sliding doors here that's funny my by
the way like we invented sliding doors
we did but you still haven't watched it
no I think it's actually better to keep
the mystery alive it is because the way
I had it in my head it was a really good
movie but the way I had it in my head it
was a better story it'll never live up
to the hype of your brain it's true so
gwenith palra was caught using her Oscar
trophy to prop open an outdoor gate on
her property in a new video interview
with v she did 73 questions um the
interviewer said what a beautiful
Academy Award she said it's my door stop
it's literally in the dirt it's outside
so funny do you think that it's really
there all the time or it's just like an
Easter egg for the video so that you
know people watch it I don't know I
could see gwenneth like not giving a
[__] about Oscars she's like Hollywood
royalty like yeah oh this whole thing
got it in 99 and also really what else
are you going to do with it other than
display it at least now it serves a
purpose no I also feel like Kim is Kim
gwenneth is very into like the
decluttering lifestyle like she doesn't
have shelves with [__] on it you know
yeah that's just how I feel like her
design aesthetic to be so I can see
people being like this is such an front
to everyone who's ever wanted an Oscar
like you don't respect the Arts and to
you I'd say get a grip and I love this
like oh this thing that so many people
CET it's in the dirt it's the [__] on my
shoe it's the [__] on my shoe that's
Queen gwenith for you putting life in
perspective as much as people find her
so unrelatable I think a lot of people
will find this relatable because a lot
of people like look at the Oscars and
and these things it's just like so
stupid and so for her to treat it that
way Queen no I love going with paltro
and nothing she does would make me
dislike her so when I win my oscar I'll
be wiping my ass with that which would
be extremely pain
ow yeah but you know what shows
them sure
sure um so yeah she's doing 73 questions
she's done it before correct uh I'm sure
she has but I I actually love 73
questions I feel like so much of the
content V oh my God I ended up on this
Tik Tok I totally forgot to say this on
the toes margar sent it to me this girl
was like I am watching a Vogue
Beauty video you know theyve like what's
in my bathroom or whatever and I clicked
on one of the links in the
YouTube description and it took me to
this Google doc that was like publicly
and it was a Conan ass Google doc where
um they had basically kept a list of all
the videos they've done and how because
I guess they use like commission links
affiliate so they post like oh here's
Rihanna's skincare routine and then they
link all the products and they make
money off of and so they have a list of
whose videos generated how much this
girl was like I feel like this is
illegal I don't know how I got here it
was fascinating let me tell you not one
of those videos made more than like
$1,000 isn't that crazy for cond Nast
and the person who you would think
wasn't even like a a big star it was
like an influencer cuz those are people
with actual influence yeah it was really
interesting who was the most do you
remember it was somebody so unremarkable
and like I don't remember was anyone
surprisingly low all literally all of
them I feel like it was like a YouTuber
like Eliza Koshi or something like who
had done really well got it it was very
interesting I love when people in like
with with high jobs like make big
mistakes and then we get to enjoy like I
know that they get fired or like
literally like it ruins their lives and
I have a lot of Sympathy For That do but
like the joy I feel like reading this
thing yeah information I would never get
when the social media manager
accidentally posts like her personal
picture to the company Instagram I don't
feel like that should be a fireable
offense um and it does bring me great
joy it does I'd be likey it's just funny
it's so relatable especially when it's
just like funny something funny like
when the Pope's Instagram like liked a
bikini model on Instagram like I'm sorry
that's funny and there you know and you
know it wasn't the pope like the pop I
don't know if I know that I don't know
if I know that no I'm totally kidding um
one thing you can like guarantee about
Jackie and I is like we will never stop
talking about the time the Pope's
Instagram like that only fans models
picture because we never got down to the
bottom of it there was really no
resolution no accountability there was
no accountability and the Catholics
deserve better they really do but from
their leadership it's just such a funny
thing that's just so you know the pope
has been a a a thing a fixture for
centuries and only fans has infiltrated
that impenetrable structure it it it
could only happen in 2023 you know so
true it was 2022 I believe but I know
what you mean you know like if you had
told the you told years prior that their
legacy when it comes to the toasters
would be liking that bikini bikini model
I wouldn't have believed it yeah it's so
funny and especially as two girls who
used to work in social media management
that's like your biggest [__] fear
you lit wake up in the middle of the
night and you're like no you wake up in
the middle of the night being like like
literally what did I post like it'll
it'll it gives you night terrors
yeah I don't think that ever happened to
me though no or at least not in a way
that was like catastropic bad you know
yeah but it's frightening you it's just
it's not good no matter how you look at
it it's really not I don't know how we
got here oh Conor asked so I just love
gwenith like unrelatable inaccessible
Rich out of touch and I want nothing
else but that and keeping it real she
doesn't change it's not like they're
like gwenth you're not reading relatable
to people like maybe try going to
McDonald's right know she has built a
billion dooll brand off of being
completely inaccessible it's beyond
inspiring yeah I love her she's like so
scrupled in her unwillingness to adapt
relate yeah no it's amazing and I and
you know what like there's proof that
like I feel like they're always saying
especially when you work as like an
influencer or a celebrity like you have
to be relatable to like sell anything
and she's just a testament of that not
being true more than that you need to be
true to yourself authenticity reads more
than relatability authenticity great
than relatability who to Thun me gwenth
gwenth I love her that's the lesson of
the day yeah and also the lesson of the
day is if GTH p is doing an Instagram
Q&A tap through every story It's the
funniest [__] you'll ever seen in your
life she that's the type of person like
she has nothing to lose like she can't
get canceled like she doesn't give a
[__] yeah love love are you ready for
our next story I guess um a little tea
on Chris Jenner and Caitlyn Jenner oh I
saw this so um Caitlyn sat down for a
British daytime program called this
morning and revealed the sad truth that
she no longer has anything to do with
the famous momager despite having being
married for 22 years and sharing two
daughters together so Caitlyn's remarks
were said to have caused some family
drama between the Kardashian Jenner Clan
a source close to the pair has shed
light on her reasons for their Rift
claiming that the exes no longer have
anything in common aside from a lack of
desire to fix their broken relationship
The Insider exclusively added to
dailymail.com that Chris believes
Caitlyn to be a completely different
person to the one she married in 1991
and that despite that's putting it
mildly sorry it's like Chris believes
her know like she is a completely
different person right to the one that
she married and despite one sharing a
life together they would now have
trouble maintaining a conversation
without it becoming awkward I imagine
it's awkward the thing is I wouldn't
expect these two to really ever be
friendly except for the fact that like
they co-parent two kids and like I'm
sure that's actually really hard on
Kendall and Kylie however um I do feel
like Caitlyn like talks a little too
much Chris never talks about Caitlyn
ever she doesn't need to Caitlyn kind of
does and it just I feel like every time
she's like Caitlyn's in this documentary
about the Kardashians like she she does
a little too much and it drives a wedge
even further between her and everyone
but I do Wonder like how they deal with
the kids well the kids are grown so it's
not like it's your parents and they're
looking after you and they have to
communicate about dropping you off for
soccer practice so it's like Kendall
Kylie can spend time with whoever they
want and move on with their lives it's
just like it adds an element of of
awkwardness yeah it does but here's the
thing both Caitlyn and Chris are staunch
supporters of Israel therefore I'm
staunch supporters of both of them and
that's where my loyalties lie today and
it seems like they're not trying like
this person said they're not trying to
make it worth they are both only thing
they agree on is that they don't want to
fix their relationship and which is fine
which is fine like communication and
relationships are not for everyone no
not every relationship is meant to last
forever we're meant to be fixed like
just leave it broken move on yeah better
than like honestly sometimes trying to
fix [__] just makes it worse and also
the Dynamics here are so complicated
intricate yeah it's so true between like
the money and the fame like and no and
and the transition of course being
married to one person who then becomes a
different person 100% I can't pretend to
know what that's like right uh this
Insider said Chris is still trying to
deal with the transition a man she fell
in love with and had kids with it's no
longer around it's as if he is dead and
she already has one dead husband to deal
with and all those emotions it's easier
to separate from it than to meet it head
on for sure for I I can sympathize with
that yeah they say that when someone
transitions it's really considered like
a death of that former person right even
when you use their old name it's called
a dead name right right so I don't think
these two need to really work it out I'm
not I'm not holding out hope for that
either no wishing them well wishing them
well as well and speaking of some
Jenners who don't seem to be problematic
today Brody Jenner is making coffee with
his fiance's breast milk okay I saw this
and I wanted to get your thoughts well
here's the thing my thoughts are really
complex cuz you know my ass tried
Olivia's breast milk one time just cuz
like I was curious you know it's not
something I'm necessarily proud of I
just thought it's like important context
before I drag someone
um it's gross and it's weird but they
ran out of almond milk what else were
they to do oh I don't know regular milk
no like SK have your coffee black 2% run
to the store creamer gopuff half and
half like I I could go on yeah like
don't they live in Malibu there's Farms
everywhere get some unpasturized [__]
they probably have a cow out back no
this is weird however I'm aware of the
you know medical benefits
of it's a good for you it's there's no
more nutritious product on the planet
full of vitamins and nutrients yeah so I
love someone putting their health first
I
do but we were just having this
conversation is like we were talking
about breast milk like being
Dairy so so it's definitely has Dairy
properties especially if you eat dairy
and then nurse but some mothers will
find that their babies are lactose
intolerant so they cut out Dairy so that
it's not in the breast milk and then
that milk wouldn't be Dairy right so I
don't feel like it would I think I don't
think it would even make for
particularly good coffee yeah I think
how did he say it tasted um it was
definitely like Instagram stick it's a
bit of a bit and I'm just finding it
very interesting I'm just obsessed with
breast milk you know and it's no we know
and if you have wow M oh shut up M
victim energy get why can't I be
obsessed with breast milk I asked Jackie
to move her water and she was like I
need to stay hydrated I'm a
breastfeeding mama like don't weaponize
your breast like no I need to stay
hydrated I'm a breastfeeding mama
weaponizing your breasts period
weaponizing your breasts um it's just
it's it's it's so fascinating to me milk
and I feel like it should be to everyone
it's a medic not MediCal it's a natural
marel Marvel for sure for babies and I'm
just glad to see like Biro Jenner he
used to be the Talk of the Town drinking
tequila out at Leo do and now he's at
home having a cup of joe with some
breast milkk I think it's beautiful it's
nice to see how people evolve that's for
sure it's a beautiful story of evolution
and I love to see like his respect for
breast milk like that's just a funny
pict it's a cute picture also the thing
about Bry Jenner is like he's really hot
and he always has been and I feel like
maybe he always will be and you could
just get away with more stuff when
you're when you're hot mhm in a man
so wishing you well wishing them well
they have a nice he really has like a
nice life and he's gotten serious yeah
settled down we respect we do be careful
also like she must be a super producer
cuz in your house you're just not giving
away milk no well now like round two I
have more to spare but she no she
obviously is doing well in production
because if she wen I would not spend
drop on anything I will never forget
never in my life forget last go around
when you were breastfeeding we were
doing a photo shoot mhm and you were
literally pumping in the trailer you put
all your milk in the fridge in the
trailer uhhuh we go to the photo shoot
we come back and they switched our
trailers like they literally drove the
trailer away and like brought in a new
one I don't I don't [__] know why it
seems like an incredible waste of money
break down break down calling the driver
it literally got the driver to turn back
around on the highway to bring her back
her two bags of breast milk yeah that's
liquid gold yeah no like imagine leaving
$100,000 in a trailer like you would go
get it too yeah no and that's just like
wrong they were wrong for that yeah no
like what if I left like what if you
left your son in there like yeah it was
just like a crazy thing to do yeah that
wasn't my fault like that was no I
wasn't saying it was your fault I was
just showing your um dedication to the
breast milk dedication yes yes for sure
even this time if I and I have like more
breast milk to spare like I would still
make them bring it back of course that's
mine that's mine I worked hard for it
right it was just like kind of like a
manipulative thing of for them to do
yeah I love how you're like when we were
on a photo shoot we did one photo shoot
once I don't know I feel like I've done
I've done like three done like three
yeah so one of the many photo shoots
that I've done don't be rude yeah no we
love doing photo shoots together we are
models for actually we hated it we our
takeaway was that models are severely
underpaid and it's the worst job in the
world yeah and honestly like people who
are there like a general thing like
people suing people always say like
modeling is easy models are dumb
couldn't be me I I could never be a
full-time model and I've gotten many
offers I'm Fielding them constantly
you're so strong so brave today's
episode is also brought to you by Master
Class um I don't know if you guys have
been like seeing me acting different
like I'm better than everyone and
smarter than everyone and it's because I
am because I took a master class with
Bob Iger because I too am trying to
become a multi multi what is he a
billionaire maybe he's a billionaire but
you know it's important to cyles for
yourself so Master Class you can learn
from the best become your best with
masterclass from leadership to
negotiating to creativity to cooking
whether you're watching masterclass on
TV listening in audio mode in their app
or on their website the quality really
speaks for itself cuz think about how
much it would cost to take one-on-one
classes from the world's best tens to
hundreds of thousands of dollars but
with Master Class an annual membership
is just $10 a month so it's basically
taking the world's leaders the world's
smartest the world's most successful and
making them your personal mentors which
most of us would never you know really
have the option to because we're all a
bunch of nobodies but but with Master
Class you're somebody and their
memberships start at $120 a year for
unlimited access to one-on-one classes
with all 180 plus masterclass
instructors so you've got former FBI
Chris bosses he's giving a negotiation
class they also have Esther Pell's
relation intelligence class it's really
amazing it's unparalleled access to some
of the world's best and brightest and
most successful and if you're looking to
like level up in your business or level
up your your self-image there's so many
different reasons why someone might want
to take a master class it's also an
amazing thing to give to someone I know
Jackie got it for someone in her life
who is in the Arts and they loved it so
boost your confidence and find practical
take takeaways that you can apply to
your life and right now our listeners
will get an additional 15% off an annual
membership at masterclass.com toast get
15% off right now at masterclass.com
toast that's masterclass.com
toast are you ready for our next story
about someone who's actually strong and
brave yes Netflix's FAA star leor RZ
joins his Brave brothers in arms on
Israel's front line to help rescue trap
families near bomb barded town of stot
after hamas's bloody Invasion so I've
been seeing this on Instagram cuz Leora
RZ is on the show F which I don't watch
yet I know I need to watch it it's
Israel show that's like so popular here
in America yeah and it's about I think
situation similar to what's happening in
Israel right now it's like mosad mad
energy Vibes whatever and he is arming
up to help rescue innocent civilians in
the isolated town of sto which is right
near the border and is constantly hit
heavily during these um conflicts and
especially this week not to make
everything about us um but he did speak
at our high school he did it was like
such an affair like like it was for the
students and like literally Lum and I
were breaking down the door to get in
cuz people love him so much had I
graduated already yeah like two years
ago oh oh okay um it was such a big deal
for the community I love this man I
respect this man I would lay my life out
on the line for this man and this is
true heroic ISM and bravery and we stand
I got to start watching F yeah I also
heard it's just like a great show heard
that for years um you know life
imitating art you know singing about
last night bar
rafaeli I feel like for so long she was
like the only Israeli representation in
like American entertainment and media
now she has a dartboard with gadot's
face on it yeah no like galgadot came
snatched Her Image up but then Bary went
through her own sort of like distressing
times I think she evaded taxes
understandable and was facing some jail
time in Israel yeah Queen what's she up
to now I don't know let's check her
Instagram yeah no I agree I feel like
for so long she was one of the faces No
and then like there was that song about
her really like bar Raphael Jazelle no
that's
Brazilian
barelli what song is that oh she's she's
popping off of course she is because she
has a duty outdo Gadot follow our next
story is about Gadot though of course
Queen she's on set with Jason Mamoa
filming a movie tied up on a rooftop in
Venice they're filming a movie called in
the hand of Dante okay I want to say
something please and I hate and I would
never speak ill of my Israeli Queen
goote even though what she did with that
imagine video she should be I think
she's thoroughly ashamed no and honestly
like has she not been punished
enough I think she has but it's
important to remember like I don't want
to send hate her way but like it was her
idea but I also but I feel like it's
misogynistic to put it all and maybe
antiemetic to put it all on her there
were a number of celebrities in that
video oh no for sure but she like
started the group chat and like told she
gave out the parts she was kind of like
the choreographer I know I hate to in
times like this to send any hate her way
um because she's a queen and I love her
um but I had something else to say not
even a bad imagine I have like a hot
take I think I know what it is like
besides Wonder Woman Like gagod Do's
movies are not good well you obviously
didn't see keeping up with the Joneses
no I didn't but I saw death on the Nile
and like she was just not giving good
acting like yeah that's what I I'm sorry
you know what I feel like this is really
not the time for me to hate on the
Israeli actress I take it back like I
really take it back no she's a queen I
like her movies she's the most beautiful
woman in the world
mhm I would take a bullet for her mhm
and it's as simple and as complicated as
that well now she's in a movie with
Jason Mamoa which got me thinking about
Game of Thrones because I feel like
since like all the Sophie Turner stuff
and everyone's like evaluating her
career and TMZ's like she hasn't Works
since Game of Thrones like who would you
say is the most successful Game of
Thrones actor Jas Mamoa and spoiler
alert he was killed off in season one
like it's crazy why because he had to go
and find other work while the other
actors were like resting on their
Laurels of this8 season show they
thought might go on forever the thing is
I would say he's the most successful but
I would say him and Sophie Turner are
like equally famous yeah but Amelia
Clark's also really famous yeah but
she's not I I think she's on a lower
level than just her personal life
doesn't seem to be interesting right no
and like she did that one movie with the
guy in the wheelchair and like what else
after that me before you which like she
did a holiday romcom for Netflix even I
didn't watch it yeah that's yikes and I
love her and I love holiday and I love
watching stuff on Netflix it's true so I
don't know where it went wrong it's
yville yeah if you're not even watching
honestly there it's just the categories
too in saturated and inundated and it
became overwhelming for me and I had to
back away from the whole cat toxic
environment dare I say Netflix like
ruined those holiday movies they like
you dare say they commercialized them
too much and like Hallmark had this
amazing thing going on and Netflix just
straight out copied it with like bigger
budgets and bigger celebrities and
honestly the beauty of Hallmark is the
lack of money and the lack of
celebrities like yeah they it was wrong
it was wrong what they did no and they
have all these huge movies with like the
Brook Shields one we watch that recently
horrible horrible even when they got
Lindsay Lohan to come out of retirement
back into ant I didn't watch it I liked
it I'm sure it was good I liked it yeah
oh they have that one with Vanessa
hudgin that was like the one thing that
they did they're like let's test out
let's steal H Rock's whole brand and see
if it works for us and they did it with
Princess Diana story whatever it's
called with Vanessa an don't forget the
an and it popped off and they also did
that other Royal first one they did
Christmas Christmas Prince a Christmas
Prince and those were two nobody's and
it was hugely successful I think they
need to go back to the nobody I was
happy for Vanessa an like for real but I
was sad for for Hallmark I can't lie
like this was their homegrown idea yeah
just completely stolen like their
intellectual property snatched you hate
to see it you hate to see it but I feel
like they came out on the other side
yeah they still do what they do like for
Netflix it was a trend and they were
just like hopping on the band so it
wasn't authentic it was not authentic
but Hallmark is still doing what they do
best
yeah what were we saying Game of Thrones
What were were you saying Amelia Clark
oh yeah no she like kind of like fell
off the face of the Earth right so who's
the most successful Jason mwa cuz who
else cuz who even like Jon Snow
literally hasn't been in anything no
there was a moment there cuz he married
the uh wildling yeah there was
excitement there and there was like she
was in Downtown Abbey yeah but you're
right small part what happened there oh
hottie McGee hottie McGee Jamie
Lannister uh he's good too other hotti
McGee I think it's his name is Richard
in real life Madden yeah The Bodyguard
oh yeah hotti McGee what happened to you
he does stuff he works he should be in
Bridgerton yeah as one of the brothers
it's a little late for that no for sure
uh he works I'm sure they all work John
Snow doesn't
work but Jamie Lannister Works he was
just in that show on Netflix and he's in
the best movie of all time The Other
Woman and when you've done that you can
just honestly when you've done that you
can only go down from there for real
like no but you can sleep easy knowing
your legacy is intact it's protected
even though he made it through all
through eight seasons of Game of Thrones
but nothing he does will ever be better
than the other woman it's kind of like a
curse to be on Game of Thrones I feel
like you could say that about a lot of
really big shows like what I have to
think like what are the succession
people going to do next nothing amazing
question I saw shiv in some turn Apple
TV show like it looked so bad sending
prayers and thoughts to her and her
whole family and it's also like
lightning doesn't strike twice for most
people for Jason Mamoa it did yeah but
maybe there's a person who got struck by
lightning twice it's Jason mimoa let me
tell you why why it happened for Jason
mimoa and I think it's like here's the
lesson of the day don't be afraid to be
different like Jason mamo's hair unlike
other hair like his whole energy like he
could have conformed to Hollywood
buzzcut you know he just like was so
himself in such a unique way I've never
seen someone so good-looking and so
different looking than other other men
you know I don't think anybody who looks
like him and his looks I'm sorry it's
not really his talent it's his looks
that took him as far as he did I'm sorry
um and he just like stood with his look
you know which was which was unorthodox
yeah that's the lesson be yourself
that's what we're saying that's what we
said about gwenth stay true to
yourself those colloquial like cringey
things are so true sometimes yeah like
the things be yourself everybody else is
taken everybody else sucks that's more
that's better yeah that's more better
that's more better the things that like
the teachers have what's popular is not
always right and what's right is not
always popular if that the damn truth
it's so true I need more like quote
cards inspirational quotes in my life
maybe for my next apartment that'll be
like my design
aesthetic teachers we have so many
teacher toasters send me your best most
oh teachers where do you get those
things Scholastic fairs for sure I don't
know they always have them like right in
time I got another one for back to
school I got another wait it was just
with me of course the Golden Rule do
unto others as you would have others do
unto you
I don't love that one easier said than
done no it's so true and also like who
is this other yeah what have what's
their history with me right context do
unto others as they deserve to be
treated by you that's bad I also don't
love an eye for an eye makes the whole
world blind if I'm blind [__] you
better be too I completely agree and
it's just one eye really so you could
still see out of the other so true but
actually if you came for my eye I'm
coming for both of yours like yeah [__]
around find out find out that should be
on the teacher
inspiration mess around and find
out you know what I absolutely love the
toes you know what else the teachers
need the camber and the counselor and
that's that's called a call back you
guys that's called Full Circle teachers
mam grandmas grandpas dads caretakers
aunties godmothers
Godfathers this is for
[Music]
you if you're not watching on YouTube
today you dismiss like an A+ choke the
God fathers need it you come to me on
the day on my PB day day so this just my
fault um my nose is
running so that's a wrap That's All She
Wrote that's all I wrote for my first
book the camper and the counselor my
children's book it's here I've worked so
hard on this book this story has been
living rfree in my mind for 5 years and
I'm so glad that you guys will be
getting copies in hands today and if
supporting Jackie like isn't Reon enough
let me give you another reason why maybe
you should buy this book it's no secret
that there's kind of this divisive
energy here at toast headquarters the
fact that your first book was written
about our other sister like not me the
other sister who doesn't work with you
every day no um and I'd be lying if I
said it wasn't hurtful but I understand
how the story came to fruition in a very
organic way and if there's any hope of a
sequel of course inspired by me Olivia
can [__] all the way off um this one she
has not been Campa been campaigning like
you okay good this one has to be
successful cuz if this one flops and
this book already is a success like I
said we're out of printing but if it's
like such an enormous success and
there's so much demand for a sequel i
canot tury l goes to the zoo except she
will be try L because I'm not going to
write a children's book about tury I'm
just not going to do it why I feel like
it's a really good way of
um introducing young people to the joys
of bowel
movements perhaps but maybe Trudy L
makes a tury Maybe if but she's got to
be Trudy well you know what we'll talk
we'll talk talk my people we'll call
your people and let's see how this one
does Ben we'll give you a call Zach
looks forward to answering so that's our
show thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast of M Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
82 every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so watching us on YouTube please
fre to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
Spotify s public radio iast box all the
places why you listen to podcast find us
the toast leave five star view about a
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
we will see you tomorrow for hump day
love you
bye